in the previous video
we left off as agent hoskins managed to
escape the overwhelming hostile mob
attacking a sarah hospital but not
without being heavily injured and losing
her partner
anderson on the other side of the
conflict zone
zanders and his unit of lnb have been
doing their best to carry out their
mission of securing and physically
downloading the server assets
from the district union bank
headquarters while being held back by a
few altercations
it was an unlikely group that came to
their aid so that they were able to
carry out their mission
melanie hoskins awakens two days later
her body and mind needing this time to
heal and recover
agent jason shu is there when she wakes
up and informs her that he's just
received a report that a nearby medical
clinic in the dark zone is under attack
hoskins are still visibly struggling
with the recollections of anderson
and how the events went down she wonders
to herself how she
would have reacted in the same situation
if it had been her husband and little
boy
while on their way to the dark zone shu
explains to her that anderson's death
was a result of him allowing his
personal problems to overwhelm his own
judgment
which resulted in him acting impulsively
and ultimately losing sight of the
overall mission
and in order for the division agents to
be successful in their mission they need
to remain calm
focused and not let their emotions get
the better of them after all
this is what they've been trained for
eventually they identify the clinic
coming up ahead of them
and note it's on fire it appears that
the cleaners are potentially nearby
approaching the building they observed
the silhouette of a person on the second
floor
when suddenly said person opens fire
upon them and the agents have to quickly
take cover
keeping themselves close to the walls of
the surrounding building they advance
carefully towards the clinic
once inside they make their way towards
the stairs however the cleaners are
waiting for them
and a remote fire bombers exploded
narrowly missing the agents
they returned fire but the cleaners
managed to escape up the stairs
and onto the second level reluctant to
encounter more of the cleaners traps
the agents look for another way to
access the second floor and discover the
fire escape
shu utilizes a new upgrade to his gear a
device which emits pulse waves that acts
as a recon device
which can spot enemies and other people
from a distance
it detects two cleaners at the top of
the stairs and another across the hall
it shows them that on the other side of
the building are six people locked in a
room
they immediately phone in the hostage
situation requesting backup
given the situation is dire as the
building is coming down around them they
don't have time to wait for a response
hastily they make the way towards the
locked room unable to move quietly
anymore as time is running out
the cleaners detect them and immediately
start advancing
the agents managed to locate the room
and she instructs the medical staff
inside the room to quickly back away
from the door
he then proceeds to shoot out the locks
unfortunately the cleaners have now
caught up with them
and promptly opened fire upon the agents
they have no choice but to take cover
and are now pinned in the same room
alongside the hostages
with the fires continuing to rapidly
spread the whole building is nearly
completely engulfed in flames
they need to make a decision and fast
employing two flashbangs and a
smokescreen hoskins provides a
distraction
while shu quickly makes his way out of
the room with the medical staff and back
down the fire escape
with the building coming down around
them their vision is blocked and under
heavy fire by hoskins
the cleaners decide to withdraw as they
begin to depart
hoskins hears one of them call out to
another johanna
she can hardly believe her is her sister
surely not
what would she be doing here why would
she be doing this
and how could her sister be one of the
people hurting all of these innocent
individuals
going against shu's orders hoskins
immediately pursues after the cleaners
the cleaners are aware they're being
followed by the division agent but
they're going into the sewers
the underground is a maze and if you
don't know where you're going you'll
quickly find yourself lost
yet hoskins is undeterred and keeps
going
eventually johanna stops sick of being
followed and unwilling to risk them
finding out where they stay
at once opens fire on the agent as soon
as she comes within sight
it is here that the two sisters both
come to the realization that they are
fighting on different sides of the
conflict
johanna claims that what she is
fulfilling is a function that no one
else has the guts to execute
that there is no way to get rid of the
virus except through the actions of what
the cleaners are prepared to do
what the government is attempting is
only making the situation worse
especially now that they have abandoned
and fled the quarantine zone
hoskins tries to plead with her sister
begging her to understand that what she
is doing is wrong
but johanna turns her back and leaves
hoskins continues to chase the fleeing
figures but eventually loses them in the
tunnels
she again tries to make contact and
calls through asking for her status
reluctantly she makes her way back the
way she came and up to the surface
emerging from the darkness shu helps her
out of the manhole
other agents have since arrived and one
of them named amsel
hoskins recognizes as the training
instructor she met all those months ago
amsoil explains that things have gotten
bad out there a lot of agents are
missing
the division need all the help they can
get
she then leaves with the medical staff
while hoskins catches her breath
and catches up with shu she was furious
he demands that hoskins explain why she
pursued the cleaners
they already had the hostages and it was
an extremely risky move to follow them
down into the sewers
she confesses to him that one of those
cleaners
was her sister and that her sister was
the one responsible for anderson's death
[Music]
taking a moment to process what she's
just said he then admits that he knows
of her sister
originally the agency had approached
johanna before they had even met
and taken an interest in hoskins and
while johanna had all of the qualities
and attributes they looked for
a soldier quick-witted experienced
adaptable
she had failed the early pre-testing
process
they identified her as being highly
misguided and overly impressionable
which given her current situation only
proved to be true
disheartened by everything that had
occurred during the operation and
particularly in what she discovered
hoskins suggests that they should visit
her sister's apartment
not that she thinks she'll be there
anymore especially now that she knows
the agents may be looking for her
but perhaps they may be able to find
something that can point them towards
the cleaners and where they're operating
they agree to check it out in the
morning and head back to base to get
some rest
the dark zone is growing more dangerous
by the day and nine days in
xander's and his l b are starting to
show signs of fatigue
and it's only time before they lose
their position
the server backup is only at 68 and due
to hardware complications
it could be another five days from
completion
they're losing men and the
representative from the bank is only
making things worse by questioning every
call
and barking out commands sanders gets in
contact with bliss
and explains the situation they're cut
off from the rest of the lmb
and unfortunately there is no hope of
reinforcements any time soon
after his conversation with bliss and
then witnessing even more of his men
getting injured due to the growing
hostile presence outside
he has finally had enough he refuses to
stand by any longer while the majority
of his men continue to get slaughtered
defending an empty building he has
already lost three soldiers
and several more have been injured
whatever this contract is worth
the safety of his men is more important
bliss has given him the ok to pull his
men out and regroup with the other lmb
units close by
he orders his men to start preparing to
move out
the bank rep is losing his mind he's
screaming at zanders
about the importance of the data that is
being stored here that the economic
stability of the country depends on it
and that xander's men aren't as
important as the mission before them
as if this wasn't enough the rep then
picks up a gun and points it at the lmb
commanding that they immediately put
their things down
unalarmed but internally seething
sanders turns his own gun upon the rep
and guns him down where he stands
surrounded by hostiles and unable to
call in support xander's turns to the
only person he believes can help him and
his men
escape johanna fisher
and yet again by using her knowledge of
the area fischer is able to guide the
unit through the sewers to a nearby
group of lmb
who have managed to secure a good
defensive position
meanwhile agents hoskins and shu find
themselves in johanna's apartment
the building is empty and it's obvious
that no one has been here for a long
time
they begin to poke around for any clues
they're able to find to help identify
where she could have gone
fortunately for them there happens to be
enough data for isaac to create an echo
which provides intel on impossible
whereabouts or at least where a crew
were last hanging out
perhaps they could find more clues there
they started heading towards a building
next to littlejohn's pizza
and went close enough they scanned the
area
isaac establishes that there are three
people inside
they seem to be preparing fire bombs
the agents quickly make their way to the
outside of the building and prepare to
engage
johanna isn't there but this is a huge
stockpile of fire bombs
and it's vital that they don't let them
get onto the streets
hoskin lobs in a flashbang disorientated
the cleaners barely have time to react
two of them are gunned down but before
the third individual is able to be taken
out too
she quickly arms one of the bombs
reacting immediately to the threat
shu throws the newly armed device
through the window before it has a
chance to detonate
in the room isaac constructs another
echo that gives the location of where
all these bombs and detonators are being
made
the cleaners call it the shop and it's
located east 20th and 3rd street
however while all of this is going on
johanna and her crew are in the process
of returning to the apartment
as they come up through the sewer
manhole she instantly notices the fire
on the street
and then looking up at the apartment she
observes the orange glow of the echo
it seems that the division has found
them and if they were able to locate the
apartment
it wouldn't be long before they found
the shop
johanna's crew suggests contacting
pharaoh and to bring in the cavalry and
relocate everything on site
knowing full well that her sister is
behind this johanna answers
no let them come
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]